Okay. All right. Um, welcome everyone to
the DDPS seminar. Uh, before we
introduce our invited speaker, let's go
over some rules and logistics. Uh, first
of all, please mute yourself during the
talk. Uh, but if you have questions, you
can unmute and ask questions. Uh, or use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in Q&A at the end.
Uh second, today's DDPS seminar is open
to external audience. Uh therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed. So,
please watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. All right, that's
about it. Uh now, let me briefly
introduce our speaker today. It is an
honor to host Dr. uh Kunihiko uh Tyra
who goes by Sam
uh who is also a professor of mechanical
and aerospace engineering at UCLA
um relatively close to us um and he's
working in unsteady aeros dynamics and
flow control using computational and
datadriven approaches. Prior to joining
his current institute um institutions,
he was a faculty member at Florida State
University. He received um his undergrad
degree from the University of Tennessee
and he's um master and PhD degree from
Caltech. is a recipient of the 2013 Air
Force uh young investigator award and
2017 uh ONR young investigator award and
2022 DoD um Venevver a Bush faculty
fellowship is a fellow of APS and an
associate fellow of
AIA. He currently serves as an associate
editor for physical review fluids and
has served as an associate editor for
AIA journal and the theoretical and
computational fluid dynamics. Today uh
Sam will talk about extreme
aerodynamics flow analysis and control
for
highly
conditions. I am sure we are going to
hear a wonderful talk. Now let me ask a
question to Sam just to get to know him
better and make him se make this seminar
somewhat informal. Okay, here is the
questions since I happen to know you
like the uh the airplane and very
passionate about the airplane. Um my
question is very simple. Why why do you
like airplane?
A good question. First of all, thanks
for inviting me to the seminar series.
Um it's quite an honor to be part of the
series. Um, some of you might know that
I I actually like airplanes quite a bit.
Um, growing up, um, I I used to fly with
my family across the Pacific. Um, my
family is originally from Japan and we
lived in the US and we traveled quite a
bit, but we always flew uh, across the
Pacific Ocean. And was always amazing to
me how these beasts can fly, you know,
being so heavy. Um, and I actually got
to join a cockpit during one of the
flights to see how it was being
operated. And that just fascinated me.
And here I am still doing, you know,
things related to airplanes. Yeah.
Probably uh for the rest of your life, I
guess you're gonna hopefully hopefully
Okay.
The floor is yours. Okay. Thank you
again, Yansu. Uh again, it's quite an
honor to be part of your seminar series
today. Um please feel free to interrupt
me at any point during this talk. Um I'm
happy to address any questions or your
curiosity uh at any point. Um it's going
to be pretty loaded in terms of the
material.
Um my talk today is going to be focused
around how to solve some of the problems
that we're interested um that we
consider to be pretty challenging using
datadriven techniques.
Um okay so I I titled it as extreme
aerodynamics. I'm going explain what
extreme means and why it's challenging.
This work is supported by the department
of defense, the veteran bush faculty
fellowship program um and also has uh
benefited quite a bit of foundational
support from the air force office of
scientific research and the army
research office over the years. Okay. So
before I get started, let me thank a few
people. We're actually a group of many
people um that used to be well some of
them used to be my students and postocs.
Uh Kyifami, Luke Smith, uh Vitis Garavi,
they were students and postocs in our
group. Um since left to join other
institutions as faculty members and
postocs um and Hoto is still with us.
He's a graduate student and I had
fantastic group of collaborators um to
work with that inspired us in applying
datadriven techniques to some of the
most challenging problems that we have
and we've also been blessed with very
understanding program managers that's
been supporting their effort over the
years. Okay. So um I told you I like
airplanes so I'm going to start with
airplanes. Um we have seen many
airplanes um over the years and they
operate for various types of missions.
They operate in different conditions and
and they serve a lot of our human needs
in various ways. So I I've shown a few
of these things and just to show you how
crazy I am, the the picture in the
middle is a airplane model that I made
and I also make models here. But all
these airplanes share one thing. um they
operate generally in steady conditions.
So they they operate in cruise
conditions. You can think of some
unsteady conditions but unsteadiness is
actually fairly mild compared to the
operating conditions time scale and
length scales. Okay. Right. For those of
you who are uh this is this is also a
picture that I took from near our house
uh dropping water and for those of you
in California this is a familiar site
fighting fire uh you know wildfires but
any case the these aircrafts are
essential to our daily lives. Okay. So
again these airplanes that I just showed
are generally based on certain things.
For example here's a picture I took out
of a window from LAX. Um if if you are
familiar with flying usually when you
fly out of an airport um you are flying
in great weather and you are clear from
obstacles there there are strict rules
and guidelines as to where you can build
airports and what kind of buildings can
surround the airport. So you can imagine
you're flying in fairly clean condition.
Now here's a picture of uh airspace of
where I used to work. I used to work in
Tallahassee, Florida. And this was a
regular occurrence, but you will notice
in the middle there's nothing. There's
no airplane over southern Georgia uh and
northern part of Florida. Um and this
happens from time to time. Does anybody
know why this happens? Can can anybody
shout at me if you can get a if you have
a
guess? Um it's very difficult to operate
in certain conditions. And some of you
are probably already thinking, let me
show you the answer. you can get an
event like this, a big vortex or a
hurricane. And in these conditions, you
certainly don't want to fly um over such
very turbulent conditions. And that's
understandable, right? In fact, trying
to fly in very gusty conditions is very
challenging and it could have some very
bad consequences on those who are flying
into the wakes. For example, here's a
A380. This is a very heavy aircraft as
some of you already, well, probably all
of you know. It generates a humongous
wake as you're seeing here with a cloud.
Now, there was an unfortunate incident
some time ago where
a small aircraft, a Challenger 640, this
was a privateely owned aircraft that
flew into the wake a couple of miles
behind this aircraft. And the result was
pretty uh pretty bad to to put it
mildly. Um here's the before and after
photo. The airplane tr uh tumbled um it
luckily didn't crash into the Indian
Ocean, but it created a lot of damage
and the aircraft was actually written
off. It was no longer fit to fly or so
they evaluated and there were some
serious injuries to the passengers on
this aircraft. And not to make it scary
or anything, but this aircraft actually
operates as a commercial jet too. So
that this is actually part of the CRJ
series. So some of you might have flown
on the commercial airline version of
this aircraft. And here the aircraft
weight difference is 25 to1 between the
A380 and this Challenger 640. So it it's
it's not like you know an unheard of
incident where you fly into a very
strong wake and you could cause serious
damages. Okay. Now um there are many
scenarios where flight operations are
restricted. Uh the previous one was one.
There are strict guidelines on the space
in between airplanes. But also, if you
think of flying in an air taxi or drone
in the wake of a building on a pretty
bad weather, you can imagine this is
going to be pretty challenging or if
you're trying to rescue someone in a
mountainous area on a gusty day. In
fact, the recent LA fire, I'm told that
some of the flight operations were
restricted due to very strong Santa Ana
winds because the planes couldn't fly
near the mountains. they have to drop
the water as close to the surface or the
fire and that was not possible during
the early stages of the firefighting
which could have contributed to the
significant damages that you've seen on
the news. But you can see that that may
not be a choice for some of the very
critical rescue missions that the DoD
goes through. Also, one of the things
that's amazing to me is if you try to
operate an aircraft behind a ship, you
are flying directly into the wake of
itself. And sometimes those wakes are
pretty large compared to the size of the
aircraft that you're trying to operate.
And these airplanes are sometimes trying
to operate autonomously, which is an
additional level of challenge that's
imposed. Okay. Now, here's a picture
I've taken from Professor Ana Jones, my
colleague at UCLA. She has an annual
review article on this. And one of the
very important parameters that we study
in the unerodynamics community is this
gust ratio. The gust ratio is the ratio
between some characteristic disturbance
velocity over the crew speed of the
aircraft. So if you imagine what the
gust would look like for a large scale
aircraft, it's actually not that severe.
So the speed of a modern let's say a 747
or any kind of commercial airlines
pretty large. Um so when you have get
hit by a gust this gust ratio is not
huge. But as you make this aircraft
smaller and smaller and say the
disturbance level hasn't changed, this
Gust ratio can suddenly become fairly
large as this U infinity becomes small.
And right now as you approach the Gust
ratio one, it's considered unflinable.
Okay. Now if you were to think of a
small scale aircraft that's operating
let's say in in an urban canyon or near
mountainous terrain where the gust
velocity or disturbance velocity is
pretty large and the speed of aircraft
is small you can imagine you're starting
to approach gust ratio greater than or
one or possibly greater than one where
the level of severity is pretty bad.
Just to give you a note, I I had a
chance to fly a uh let's say uh take
part in a flight simulator for a 737
gust ratio of 0.1 was very uncomfortable
and hard to maneuver the aircraft. So I
can only imagine what would happen if
you go closer to the gust ratio one. It
must be very difficult to even keep the
aircraft a lot. Okay, just to give you
an idea, this is the kind of planes that
we're going to be considering in our um
discussions today and we're going to
make this a much more simpler model, but
think of a flat, you know, wing or a
wing like this, flying in air, taking
off vertically or landing or flying
directly into the gust. Okay. All right.
So, let me now get into more of the the
sort of the details of extreme
aerodynamics and explain what the
challenges are. Okay. So again if you
think of large scale airplanes and
trying to operate in a steady dynamic
conditions you have some base operating
conditions that you want to achieve and
you might have some perturbations due to
turbulence in front or maybe some
external factors. We know how to operate
airplanes um in this kind of condition.
We know how to do it pretty
well. If you're adventurous you can also
get into conditions where you're
operating airplanes in a quasi steady
environment. For example, if you're
brave, you can fly into a hurricane.
It's going to be very uncomfortable, but
that's possible. People do that for
scientific research purposes. Or your
airplane can change its geometry
mid-flight, and that would be considered
quasi steady. But the point is that the
perturbation doesn't evolve as fast as a
bay flow. Okay. The conditions that
we're going to be considering in this
talk in our in our research area is when
the level of the disturbance now is
becoming as close to the base condition.
So if you want to think about the
amplitude, the amplitude is important.
But also what's also important here is
the spatial and temporal scales of
disturbance is now becoming close to the
base flow and may be difficult to
distinguish one from another. Okay. And
these are the conditions that we're
interested in. Now, why is this
challenging? Well, as you can imagine,
the disturbances are large. Now, so
linear theory is likely not going to be
valid in many cases. The dynamics are
going to be inherently transient. So, we
can't just simulate one steady
condition. We're going to have to
capture all the transient conditions
that we're interested in. Another thing
is we don't think about this maybe
enough but we need to select the
appropriate model promise that captures
the important inherent transients right
okay
um oh another thing I guess that's
important is we don't have a textbook on
this topic so which makes it
exciting timing base flow needs to be
considered right so most of the analysis
that we've learned over the years is
based on a steady operating condition or
a fixed point now we have to consider
Consider at which part of the time
varying base flow is the physics
happening. Are the disturbances hitting
the wing at certain phases? Those are
things that we have to consider. So now
it makes it parameters even larger in
terms of the space that we have to
consider with experiments or
computations. Because of that we are
going to be left with massive data sets
that we have to consider. So from the
given data set how we find uh physical
insights or extract physical insights
and it is desirable in this case to get
a low dimensional representation of the
extreme aerodynamic events which I'll
talk about today. Okay. Um with some
notion of this dynamics in some
lowdimensional space um we're hoping
that we can get situational awareness
around the aircraft in real time and if
possible control the aircraft to achieve
a stable flight and stable flight may
mean something different especially if
you don't have a human being on the
aircraft right and as I'll talk about
later one of the major challenges we
need to control it to act fast before
the transients are gone right these
transients are going to be violent as
you'll see later and we need to make
sure that we act fast enough to combat
those transients. Okay. All right. One
of the things that's going to make it
really challenging if you're going to
really think about trying to fly in
these turbulent conditions, there are
different types of disturbances that
we're going to encounter and I'm only
going to be able to scratch the surface
in this talk. Um, and that is through
model problems. So here I'm going to
show you a very simple toy problem. Um
here is a air uh wing that is being hit
by a vortex gust. These vortex gusts by
the way are strong. But you might think
well this seems like a very simple case.
Yes indeed it may seem that way but it
will quickly become difficult. This is a
2D laminer flow at reos number 100. It's
fine for our purposes because it
captures a massive separation. Even in
this case we have a large parameter
space of the vortex strength the size
the position at which it hits the wing
in the 3D case the orientation too the
profile of the vortex right this is a
velocity profile on the attitude side we
can consider different angles of attack
air foil shapes the timing at which the
wing is hit by the vortex and not to
mention even reo's number mock number
amount of noise that we can add on top
of this kind of flow Right? So what this
amounts to is something really
interesting. It quickly becomes a huge
data set even for a two-dimensional
analysis. So here what I'm showing is
just varying three different parameters.
The initial position of the vortex in a
vertical sense that's where it hits the
wing. The size of the vortex that's the
vortex size D and the gust ratio I
mentioned earlier. So the gust ratio we
go way beyond one in this case. In fact,
in some of the cases, we consider gust
ratio as high as 10. Okay. And here are
five different angles of attack. Some of
them are in very high angle attack
conditions where it's already separated.
But we're we're considering each of
these cases, right? One dot. But each of
these cases consider a time series of
snapshots, which makes it basically
hundreds of cases making it thousands of
snapshots of data. What I'm showing here
are the vorticity field. Right? So the
movies are showing how the flow field
evolves when the vortex hits. And as you
can imagine, you don't want to be flying
in these situations because the lift
fluctuations are pretty large. In
extreme aerodynamics, we consider a gust
ratio of larger than one where the role
of the vortex gust and the actual wing
starts to flip themselves. Right? So if
the gust ratio is greater than one, that
means the gust is stronger in terms of
the effect than the wing. Now, so uh we
call gust ratio greater than one extreme
aerodynamics in this case. Okay. Now let
me just take a few wakes out of the
movies and show you what they look like.
Um so over here in the dash line boxes
these are the wakes without
disturbances. These are the common ones
that you might have seen. These are
nodable 12 air foils with carbon
shedding or steady wake in some cases.
Right? And the corresponding lift is
shown as a dash line or curves on the
left side for different angles of
attack. And these are the vorticity
field. When you hit these wings with
strong vortex gusts, right, then you see
massive separation. You have also
different types of vortices being
generated. The lift fluctuations are
about 10 times higher in magnitude than
the original fluctuations that you'll
see for the baseline. and it is all over
the place for different cases. Shown on
the left, these different curves are
different cases of gust airflow
interactions. Okay, there's no simple
ways to scale them through simple
scaling arguments here. It's very
difficult. But one of the things that's
kind of nice for us aerodynamicists is
that when we look at the flow field, we
can identify structures easily with our
eyes. We can say what's separated,
what's not. So to our trained eye,
although these look very complicated, we
can still follow the flow field and just
make sense out of what's happening here.
Okay. All right. Now, let me start by
showing what you might be able to do in
terms of compressing all these data. So
what we're going to do now is we're
going to take all the snapshots that we
considered for all the hundreds and
thousands of cases and snapshots that
we've conducted. Let's just stick them
into PCA or
POD. plot the coefficients in time,
right? And if you were to just plot the
first three coefficients, this is what
you'll get, right? So, if you want to
reproduce a reference flow field and you
consider POD reconstruction, it does a
horrible job. And rightfully so, we
don't expect this to work pretty well.
If you were to plot the time coefficient
variations over space, it's all over the
place, right? the colored version, the
colored lines are showing the baseline
cases and the gray lines in the
background, the messy ones that look
like, you know, just a splatter of
spaghetti. That is all the disturbed
cases. Okay? And in fact, the angle
attack information is not even in the
right order. So it it does something. It
collapses information, but it doesn't
really do a good job. Okay? Now, let's
take this a little further. What we did
next, what we said, well, how about we
consider a nonlinear compression and
this is a fairly standard technique. You
stick it into an autoenccoder. You take
all the flow field information again and
then you try to compress it using an
hourglass like setup using a
convolutional net and a multi-layer
perceptron and we want to compress it to
these bottleneck variables or this
lating space variable Z. And we're
hoping that we can reproduce the
original image from the this setup. And
if we can, we're saying that the
information is compressible here. Right?
So if you do so, it turns out you can
compress it very well. Even though you
have hundreds of different cases,
different angles of attack, the
autoenccoder does a fantastic job at
compressing information only down to
three variables, right? And still be
able to reconstruct the flow field
pretty accurately, not perfectly. And
here's the error, L2 norm error, which
is about 20%. But as as far as I'm
concerned as an aerody aerodynamicist, I
can identify vertical structures here.
So I say this is pretty good. And if you
were to look at the latent space by this
represented by these three latent
variables, it does a fairly good job.
Now the um baseline cases are right in
the order 20°, 30°, 40, 50, 60° and
they're increasing order. You still get
a blob of data which is very difficult
to understand. Okay, but this is an
improvement. The big thing here is you
just need three variables to represent
all the cases that we were talking about
earlier which is a huge well discovery
for us. Okay. Now what was interesting
here was to do the following a very
simple change to the autoenccoder setup
was to add a side network. So now you
take the latent space variable and say
well can you make sure those latent
space variables know something about how
to reproduce lift right this choice was
made judiciously by us it wasn't by
accident we said we want to make sure
that the latent space variable z knows
something about lift because of two
important reasons first of all if we're
trying to fly an aircraft we want to
know something about lift you think lift
is important for flying. Okay, maybe
that's a no-brainer. The second thing is
that we also wanted to make sure that
whatever information gets
compressed is compressed in the right
way such that the compression honors
vertical structures that are important
for lift generation or has some
correlations to lift. And we know this
from aerodynamics because we
know lift is related to circulation,
right? So there's an intimate
relationship between the vorticity field
and lift. So this turned out to be a
very good choice. And if you look at
this now the latent space looks as such.
So now what we're able to do is find a
three-dimensional space where all the
information is ordered in the right way
and evolving as such around these
baseline cases. And what we're doing is
we're essentially identifying an
inertial manifold for this extreme
aerodynamic cases. And also even with
this extra side network, the
reconstruction seems to be doing fairly
well. The air goes up slightly, but
again we're doing really well in terms
of the flow field reconstruction and as
you'll see later the lift
reconstruction. Okay, so this to us was
really amazing in a sense that we're
able to go from a humongous database,
not just one case of vortex airflow
interaction, but a collection of cases,
wide ranging case of the vortex airflow
interaction to just three variables. And
those three variables are now lying on a
latent space that's represented pretty
nicely. Now you might wonder well what
are these three variables representing
physically? This is where our interest
really got peaked. Now if you were to
think of Z 1 and Z 2 where you're seeing
these circles these are like
oscillators. Now if you have vertical
formations and shedding these this Z 1
and Z 2 axes are showing how the
vortices are generated and shedding over
time. And the Z3 direction is
representing the vertical direction is
representing the effective angle attack
of the physics. So let's say a vortex is
hitting the wing and the wing is
experiencing more lift or decreased
lift. Getting more lift is like
instantaneously generating or increasing
your angle attack. Right? So that to us
is going upward in this angle Z3 or this
axis Z3. So this to us is representing
the effective angle attack. Okay, so in
a sense this is a limit cycle behavior
plus a effective angle attack summarized
really nicely in this threedimensional
space. Okay, so this was for us super
exciting. Okay, now you can project
various cases right of gust airflow
interactions onto this three-dimensional
space and see how the dynamics behave.
Now in these cases you'll see gust ratio
minus and positive that means different
orient uh well uh rotation directions of
the vortex but you can see how the
dynamics evolves about the nominal
trajectory shown in this um now gray
cases and you can see that in some cases
if the vortex is developing um with a
different color over the wing now the uh
rotation of that trajectory goes around
in a sept in in a different direction.
So this really captures everything about
the dynamics that we're interested in.
Now here's the interesting case. We
didn't train with gust ratio 10. That
was not part of the training data, but
you can see that it still does pretty
well. So even though you have a
tremendously large gust hitting a wing
and it rightfully departs away from the
nominal trajectory, this inertial
manifold is still able to capture the
essential dynamics really nicely in a
three-dimensional manner. Right? Okay.
Now all these were done with single
vortex hitting a wing and that was part
of the training data. What is amazing
with the autoenccoder, especially with a
convolution neural net, is you can now
handle more than one vortex hitting a
wing. So, we abused this poor little
wing. We hit it with multiple vortices.
In this case that we're showing, we're
hitting it with five strong vortices.
Pretty strong, right? And then what we
were able to do was we were still able
to capture the interaction between the
vortices and the vortex and the wing
over time and represent it on three
variables. This was great for us because
instead of just flying into one vortex,
this ends at the possibility of
capturing the dynamics of a wing flying
into a more turbulent condition. Okay,
there are some limitations here, but
this was really cool. Wait, say
somebody. Yeah, me. Uh um so here the
the autoenccoder only has seen the
single vertices. That's correct. But the
for the inference the testing you
introduced intentionally multiple
vertices and see how it captures. Yes,
that's correct. Interesting.
Interesting. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. This is
really interesting. And this is the
power of convolution neural nets where
they take information from different
parts of Yeah. uh and still be able to
capture the essence of the flow uh flow
structures. Okay, there are cases where
it fails. If there's so there's strong
upstream mixing like really like
turbulent flow, then this won't work
really well. But if there are still
distinct vertical patches hitting the
wing, it does really well. We were
surprised how well this worked.
Interesting. Interesting. Okay. Right.
Yep. All right. So now let me now talk
about more of the dynamics and how we're
going to handle this. So all this was
really cool from a point of compression.
Now we have all this data put on an
immersial inertial manifold right so we
originally were excited that what we're
getting is a huge amount of data
compressed onto a three-dimensional
variable right but if you look at this
manifold from top down it's actually not
3D it's actually 2D because you're
projecting on a surface right so if you
imagine that you're projecting on this
kind of like a paraboid like shape what
you're really doing is now you're able
to compress all those extreme
aerodynamic trajectories onto a
two-dimensional space of simply r and
theta. Right? So now this gives us an
idea of like well can we look at all
these complicated things as simple as a
representation using a radius and a
face. Okay. All right.
So let me let me get back to this point
right now. One other thing I want to
mention is that you don't necessarily
need to retain the input of all the flow
field. Now that what we've done is we
have a way to get from the input flow
field to the output flow field using an
encoder and decoder. Now that I've
trained the encoder and the decoder, I
can remove the encoder, keep the
decoder, and then replace the input
signal with pressure measurements,
right? and then say the output is the
latent space variables, right? And have
a training that goes from pressure data
to the latent variables. And once I have
a nice encoder, this new encoder from
the pressure sensors to the latent
variable, I can still use the same
decoder to represent the reconstructed
flow field. Right? So what this allows
us to do is to have a sensorbased flow
reconstruction
mechanism. Right? So this was pretty
exciting to us because if you were
trying to do pressure data straight to
the flow field, it was very difficult to
train. But if you have a way to have
this intermediary variable, the latent
variable, you can go for pressure data
to the latent space variable and then
you can do the reconstructor later if
you need to. Right? So we also tried
these kind of ideas with experimental
data with our friends with T Brownwalk.
Um it worked out pretty nicely. So,
we're pretty excited that these types of
machine learning algorithms can really
help with reconstruction of the flow
field or even the force measurements on
um flying bodies. Okay, now let me get
back to the phase-based concept. Right?
So, we just talked about how you can go
from a large amount of data to a
two-dimensional concept. Right? Now, I'm
going to I'm going to talk a little bit
about fundamental stuff and I'm going to
get back to my original problem. Now let
me take a little detour and explain just
why I'm interested in these phase type
concepts. Now I'm going to now suddenly
go to the experimental world. This was
uh a collaboration with my colleague
Professor Jones group from the
University of Maryland. Since then she
has moved to UCLA. We recruited her to
UCLA and she's now my uh nextdoor
neighbor. This was uh a water um a toe
tank experiment in water uh at reos
number a thousand cord based rain number
where a flat plate wing is being
translated to the left and this the PIV
measurement showing the vorticity field
and it's now being hit by a transverse
gust. So there's a jet that goes from
bottom to upwards and you saw that
there's massive separation that takes
place. Let me play that again.
Okay, you'll see on the top of the top
surface of the wing, you'll see this
vortex forming. It separates and now
it's out of the jet. Okay, so this is a
inherently a transient process, right?
However, uh our postto back then, uh
Luke Smith, now he's in Texas, uh said
well isn't this really a cyclic problem,
right? You have a wing, it gets hit by a
vortex or hey gets gets hit by a jet
generating this vortex and then leaves
the jet. So it goes from one to two to
three in terms of states and goes back
to one. Right? So we said well that's
true. Is there any way we can identify
this cyclic process? And it turns out
there's a way to use topological data
analysis. We use persistent homology
type concept where we can find a hole
right this circle or cyclic relationship
embitted in the flow field data. I won't
go into the details, but what you can do
is you can take your large dimensional
flow field data and go through this
persistent homology analysis to find if
there's a hole in your data, right? And
then you can use that information to
say, well, can you then compress your
information or the flow field onto this
circle, right? And embed that into
autoenccoder. It turns out you can,
right? So what this allows you to do is
instead of going through time you can
now go through in phase right so let's
say you go from the first
um cycle or cycle phase now you're
entering the jet you're going through
the jet so this will be three and then
you're exiting the jet right so now you
can go through the
problem through a phase like concept
right so if you think of this is theta=
z you're going through this 2 pi
argument
and you can get out of this jet and then
you're going back to this cyclic
relationship. So now we're now able to
represent ideas in terms of very just
simple theta right and it turns out you
can do this for various cases stronger
jets different angles of attack etc etc
so here is the gust ratio G now it's
called GR here but based on different
gust ratio you start from the original
point you go through a circle but if the
gust is stronger that circle is going to
be bigger right so now you can generate
basically a class of these circles And
that's what we're representing as a
manifold. And you can see that how
different angles of attack would
generate different circles here. If you
have a diff if you have an interesting
maneuver where the wing is going through
the jet but maybe tilting or pitching up
or pitching down, you can actually
generate that um trajectory on this or
in this latent space and rec recreate
the flow field as well. So what I'm
trying to say is the last problem we had
the vortex wing interaction here we're
have the wing jet interaction and we're
still able to identifying these
manifolds right and still represent
everything in terms of this r and theta
argument okay so why is this really
important for
us now I like to read some books from
time to time when I travel overseas and
I happen to be able to read Japanese and
I was able to pick up A very nice book
written by professor Kamoto. Some of you
might know that name. His name is on
equations, right? Cromodo
equations. C has this nice beautiful
book written in Japanese on phase
reduction
analysis. And I was really fascinated by
this and let me explain what this is
really about. If you have a flow field Q
dot is equal to F of Q. Think of this as
an ambios equation. And let's say it's a
periodic flow. So you have theta dot
right which is dependent on Q and theta
dot the phase if you take the time rate
of change of it that's a natural
shedding frequency right so think of
theta changing from 0 to 2 pi over a
certain time that's really the the
frequency angular frequency here right
now if you were to look at this equation
and say theta dot is equal to some phase
function that takes a variable Q your
flow state Q this can be written is a
gradient of theta time q dot. That q dot
now can be represented or replaced by
the right hand side of your governing
equation in every sto equation s and
that's still omega n. Right?
This gradient of theta is called the
phase sensitivity function. And it tells
you if you were to take a inner product
of that with f at the right time or not,
how would you how sensitive would that
be in terms of the um your phase
dynamics? And this is really cool
because what we were able to see from
all this analysis that first of all you
are now representing the flow field in
terms of a single variable phase. So
this is like a really ultimate vision of
reduced order modeling, right? if you
have a periodic system and once you know
where you are on your limit cycle we can
go back to the flow field. Now I got
really excited about all this because as
you see in your previous slides we now
have r theta representation right now it
turns out if you have the representation
there's quite a bit you can do for
example if you know this phase
sensitivity function here that you can
evaluate on the limit cycle you can see
when and how you can introduce an
external force or perturbation to change
your um synchronization behavior
different. So you can synchronize to a
different frequency content, right? So
let's say you have external forcing
that's operating at a different
frequency. In some cases, you can
imagine the flow can synchronize to that
oscillating frequency, the forcing
frequency. In some cases, you can't
right a simple u simple example would be
something like flow control, right? And
it turns out there are vast array of
tools and theories already developed.
One of which is called fast
synchronization. Now this really got our
attention because if we want to fly in a
highly gusty environment, I need to make
sure that the action of control that
we're going to introduce can act within
one cycle. Because if I introduce
control and the action of
control is felt 20 shedding cycles
later, it's too late for us. Right?
That's standard flow control. There's
active flow control communities that are
working on introducing the right types
of perturbations and forcing input so
that the steady cruise condition is
improved. That's a different problem.
That's a great problem, but that's not
what we're looking for. What we want to
make sure happens is you introduce a
forcing input right now and then we need
a response right then right and it turns
out fast synchronization method allows
us to use this phase sensitivity
function and see an effect within one to
two shedding cycles. So we got really
interested and we tried this idea for
the problem that we showed earlier. So
this is the latent space behavior of the
flow field, right? So we're taking an
example for an alpha= 40°. It's pretty
high angle attack and you're hitting it
with a gust of 2.8 in terms of gust
ratio. We can quantify the phase
sensitivity function based on the phase
reduction analysis.
Given that information, we can construct
the right optimal forcing input that
ensures that we would see some changes
within about one conveictive time. Right
now, this is not going to be perfect
yet, but we were actually happy to see
that the right kind of forcing input
introduced at the leading edge as a
blowing mechanism right here for a
controlled
case allowed us to suppress CL by about
40%. Okay. And it looks like here if you
just look at the fluctuation, it's
actually closer to half. But this was
really great for us because we didn't
know whether this was going to be
achievable within this short amount of
time. This is still far from allowing us
to claim that we can fly these kind of
airplanes in air in very gusty
conditions. But this gives us hope that
maybe something there's we can do. There
are also other things that we have to
consider for flying in these conditions.
Okay. Now I'm going to run out of time.
So let me start moving a little
faster. I have a few more slides on what
needs to be done. So how are we going to
extend our efforts right now? First of
all, we also can consider dynamic
maneuvers. So only thing we consider was
just fixed wing and then we're
introducing pertabbations. We can
dynamically move our wings. uh Hiroto
who's a graduate student has looked into
this problem and what he's finding is
that if you were to dynamically maneuver
the wing you can also represent the flow
field in a very concise manner using the
similar type of analysis that we have
you would get different manifolds. So
again the key words here is we're
finding different types of manifolds and
we're finding a zoo manifolds right? So
instead of going from this massive data
set, now we're establishing different
shapes of manifolds that maybe we're
going to be able to combine uh in future
efforts.
Okay, what I've shown you earlier were
for laminer flows. We of course if you
want to fly some of these objects, we're
going to have to consider turbulent
flow. And when you go to turbulent
flows, the flow is a lot more complex.
It's challenging as you can imagine. So
here are some cases where you have gust
ratio one to two to five. This is for a
2D wing but a 3D flow field span wise
periodic. These can be compressed to
threedimensional latent space but the
interaction dynamics is a lot more
complex. So we have to think well do we
need to to capture every little
structures in the flow field? The answer
is most likely going to be no because
some of these turbulent flow structures
don't really impose much lift
fluctuations on the wing. So we have
some ideas that we're exploring right
now. for example, can we extract only
the key structures that are large and
important for imposing those large
fluctuations? And I think we can, right?
So, we're looking at the scale
separation decomposition by professors
goto's group at the university Osaka
University. This seems to be pretty
powerful
tool and we're also looking into
threedimensional effects. So again,
Hiroto the graduate student who's
working with us is looking at well what
happens if you have tip effects and this
turns out to be a really interesting
problem because we thought the 2D
problem was very interesting to begin
with but once you have three-dimensional
effects where you have tip effects the
vortex dynamics becomes extremely
complicated right so you just saw a wing
being hit oops
sorry by a vortex a span wise aligned
vortex and it turns out the tip vortex
can play an crucial role in possibly
reducing these lift
fluctuations. It also tells us at which
point that you want to have the tip
vortices influenced more or less. And
we're currently looking into how to take
advantage of those as we try to tame the
extreme aerodynamic influence of these
perturbations. Okay. All right. Another
thing that we've been working with was
Steve Bruntton's group which was pretty
exciting was well if we have these large
vortices hitting a flying object and if
you want to go from point A to point B
and think of this as a model building so
you're flying in the wake of a building
how do we take advantage of these
structures there's been some 2D studies
that's been done in the past but we
thought of taking advantage of the
three-dimensional nature of the vertical
wake and it turns out there are some
structures that you can fly into and
rotate around it so that you can fly
from point A to point B in a more
efficient fashion. So this was a study
that's about to come out in the journal
flow and we thought this was really
interesting because you don't need that
much foresight to take an advantage of
these flows. So you just need about
about a shedding cycle that you have to
predict and I think those are fairly
easy to predict if you can use machine
learning based tools. Okay, here's one
thing that I want to bring everybody's
attention to that is a huge area where
we don't have a lot of studies is if you
have base flows with strong acceleration
or deceleration. So these are time
varying base flows the influence of the
base flow onto the perturbation dynamics
is not studied much. It is studied for
some periodic flows using flow K
analysis and there are some knowledge
based on some prior observations. For
example, acceleration tends to stabilize
the flow and deceleration tends to
destabilize the flow faster and we know
that. But there's not a lot of tools
that turns out to be available for us
and rightfully so because these are more
expensive analysis. We've been looking
at optimal um optimally timed dependent
mode analysis with our friends at the
University of Pittsburgh. That's
professor Hassan Ba's uh group. You
could analyze the modal structures as
the vortex is hitting the wing and it
tells you precisely when and where the
perturbations can grow. Uh we also been
looking at linear um optimal uh
perturbation theory to identify how much
these perturbations can grow. So you can
see for accelerating base flow the
growth rate is about 10 to the first
power but if you decelerate if you have
a decelerating uh flow profile that is
increased by 100 times right two full uh
well let's say two orders of magnitude
which is significant if you want to see
how we can deslight the flow to induce
mixing or whatnot and there's a survey
coming out where we try to uh talk about
these items um and um hopefully
stimulate people's interest in this
football field or in this research area.
Okay, I have a little bit of time. So,
let me also mention one thing that I
want to talk about. I'm trying to talk
about these things a lot. We also work
in the area of super resolution with
machine learning and this is something
that we've worked on for a few years
with Kai and the causes is pretty
interesting. You know, if you were to g
take a unders sampled coarse image, can
you basically reconstruct a flow field
that's high resolution like the example
shown here in 2D isotropic turbulence,
right? We're doing this not only from a
point of view of super resolution, but
we're also saying if each of these
pixels were sensor data points, right,
like pressure measurements or what have
you, can you reconstruct a flow field?
So this is a really an inverse problem
to reconstruct a flow at
large and you can do this amazingly well
using machine learning if you know how
to embed the right kind of structures
into your formulation. If you do a cubic
by cubic interpolation for to
reconstruct the flow from these cases to
uh reconstruct the reference data on the
left you don't do well. But it turns out
if you do the right kind of machine
learning you can do pretty well even for
a 4x4 grid you can reconstruct it so
that you can at least get the turbulent
flow structures right which was pretty
amazing in some sense. Now this requires
some data and even in some of the cases
even if you try to cut corners and do
really well um you need an order of a
100 or maybe 50 data snapshots to
reconstruct a flow and we said well can
we do even better with that? So compared
to standard machine learning with image
science, our data that we deal with and
physics is usually rich of let's say
dynamics or patterns or information even
from a single snapshot. So we said well
maybe if we are pretty smart about how
to train and how to learn from even a
single snapshot we can probably do a lot
better. And this paper it says in review
it's already published is we said well
can you learn from a single snapshot and
this was applied to the case of a super
resolution for not just isotropic
turbulence but also for a turbulent
boundary air flows. It turns out you can
if you know how to do so. So I think
this we we're now at a stage of yes we
have a lot of data but I think we're
going to have to start learning how to
train our machine learning models in a
smart way. So even a little bit of data
can get us pretty far or you know stop
being wasteful right data is really not
cheap getting high fidelity data is an
endeavor on its own. Okay just to give
you an idea here's an example where we
use a single snapshot learning to
reconstruct a flow field from low
resolution or low reos number to high
reos number cases. It does a pretty
fantastic job. Okay, again this is this
result is already published now. Okay,
so just going to throw this concluding
remarks up there because I'm I'm almost
out of time. Um we looked at the case of
extreme extreme aerodynamic flows as an
example. Uh this is something we're
interested in uh as a project. So we
have a lot of people involved in it.
What I want to say here today is that
yes I talked about a specific type of
full problem but if you have a problem
where transients are really important if
you have a lot of different cases they
have to consider I think the approaches
that we took today can be applicable to
your study as well and if you have a
similar problem that you're dealing with
and have gained insights I'll be very
happy to you know exchange information
and have a discussion as to what are the
approaches that you have taken right
We've taken an approach to go from a
highdimensional data to a phase-based
analysis and understanding of the flow,
hoping that that will give us a very
cheap way to represent the physics, but
still effective in terms of how to get
to the desired uh trajectory in a pretty
quick matter. Um, and one of the open
questions that we're now currently
looking into with our postto Barbara is
how do we take all this information and
be able to design a wing that does
really well in these very challenging
flight conditions. So with that, let me
thank our group and thank you for your
attention and the invitation to speak
today. Thank you very much. Thank you.
Thank you so much for the wonderful
talk. Uh, thank you. That is very nice.
Um, let's has let's have a Q&A session.
Sure. Uh, okay. I see the hands up. Uh,
Looney, do you want to unmute yourself
and ask question?
Yeah. Hi, thank you. Hi. Uh, hi,
Professor Tyler. Yeah, thank you so much
for your great talk. And, uh, yeah, I
have two questions basically. Uh, the
first one is about the data
representation. uh based on the figures
you show it looks like you uh currently
use a CN based uh network and uh you
take like single image instead of videos
and uh the question is like for example
your external flow actually using CNN
you cannot re uh represent the geometry
very accurately right because it's still
some pixel wise things and view it but
but you your result I would say looks
very good so I just wondering if you
think at some point this kind of
representation matters like you have to
use some GNN and uh yeah that's the
first point of the data representation
and the second part is like looks like
when you're building the autoenccoder
you just take the single image instead
of model it as a video like to consider
the temporal dynamics and I think
probably if the scenario be becomes more
challenging like turbulence it's
probably is better to model the right
the temporal coherence by some some kind
of like a video models uh transformer to
to to uh model to build the auto encoder
and uh the the second part is about the
a control problem. So uh I didn't uh
quite uh follow the the flow. So I
remember uh in probably PowerPoint 32
you have a showcase but I actually
didn't uh remember which variable
variable are you trying to control. Did
you control the angle of attack or uh
yeah maybe you can answer it later and
and it looks like such yeah s such
setting is pretty suitable for
reinforcement learning to do some
control problem. So I just wondering if
you have any ongoing project or you want
to leverage the reinforcement learning
to do the control problem. Yeah that's a
maybe a little long but anyway yeah you
can yeah I hope to get some answer uh
some some yeah some feedback from you.
Thank you so much.
I mean that's those are excellent
questions and they're they're they're
sort of uh on our minds as well as we're
struggling with some of the major um
challenges. Uh first of all let me
answer a a question about uh you asked
about the pixelwise representation.
Right.
So you're right these are fed in almost
like pixels. So they're discretized on a
cartisian grid essentially and they're
fe feeding it into the convolution
neural net. That's absolutely correct.
Right now we're not too worried about
the resolution of the data that we
provide. But there are cases where we
have to worry about that. In fact we
have another project with an automotive
company where we are taking um geometry
information from a car. were actually
pixelizing it in 3D and then feeding
that information to get um other
aerodynamic information out. Um use of
DNN has been conceptually very beautiful
and we want to do it but it's been very
difficult in terms of some of the
training data sets that we've had. So
there's a in my opinion there's a little
bit of a a transition and a gap between
what the simple problems can um be this
the problems that the difficulty of the
problems that can be handled by GNN and
when it gets really complicated GNN has
been very difficult for us in in the
applications that we've been seeing. So
hopefully we can make headways there and
that's still a challenge that we're
we're seeing. GNN for this particular
problem probably will work um due to the
laminer nature of the flow. But as we're
going to turbulent flows, GNN might have
challenges because of the way it needs
to be trained. So that's something on
our mind. If you have thoughts about it,
I would really love to follow up on it
because this has been bugging us, really
bugging us. Okay, let's see. Uh you had
some questions about the Did I answer
all the questions about this slide? Were
there another question? Sorry. Oh, you
asked about the video. Yeah. Yeah, the
video like You're absolutely correct.
You're absolutely correct. If we can use
a video input to do this, this will be
something of interest. We in fact
thought about how to compressed um video
type compressions to look at um
uh a really cheap comp uh representation
of the flow field, but we haven't
actually combined that with this
formulation yet. So that's something
that we possibly could consider because
you're right, the dynamics is not really
embedded cleanly in a nice way yet,
right? So we're kind of hoping that the
correlation is going to be pulled out
hopefully nicely. So that is not
guaranteed. So you're absolutely right
about that. And the last question I
think you asked about uh the
objective of the control, right? Yeah.
So this is this is where it gets a
little tricky. Now when I say tricky um
this is where the insight from fluid
dynamics helps and this is not very easy
for us to enforce in maybe reinforcement
learning or machine learning. We know
that if you are able to change
information about phase as a fluid
mechanician what that relates to is
we're changing the vortex shedding
behavior. So this is purely based on
knowledge, right? Not based on data. And
if we know how to change the timing of
shedding and how the shedding change in
frequency will relate to the size of the
vertical structure shedding, we know
that controls lift. Right? So through
that argument, we're using this fast
synchronization argument to say we'll
change the timing of shedding. And we
know through that change, we're hoping
that lift is going to be changed. Right?
So it's a little bit of a secondary
argument that we're counting on. It
might be possible for us to enforce or
formulate a reinforcement algorithm
where that whole thing is put into a you
know is given as a lift or I'm sorry a
loss function and you optimize it. But I
have a feeling that optimization process
is going to take a pretty long time
because it's it's not an easy concept to
go from just random initial starting
point to an optimal forcing mechanism. I
hope that answers your question, but it
may be possible. I'd love to be proven
wrong about that, but we're trying to
make sure that students graduate on
time. So, we're going to make sure that
these can be achieved in a fairly quick
manner. Yeah, got it. Yeah. Thank you so
much uh for these answers and I might
follow up about some opinion I have but
yeah there are a lot of other questions
so yeah I will follow up absolutely
absolutely would love to chat more thank
you all right well thank you um next you
um you can unmute and ask question
hi thank you for the great presentation
I I really learned a lot and I enjoyed
uh uh your presentation you know as as
myself as a former air force officer and
also atmospheric scientist at Lemore
working on climate modeling and also
personally aviation gig. So it was
great. I really loved it. So I have one
commenting question uh you know this is
uh not necessarily in the scope of your
your uh work but you know this is just
you know question from uh the uh who is
working I mean who is not working in
machine learning also. So uh I one one
of comment that I have is about uh your
I think it was shown in your slide 40
which is about super le resolution. Yes.
I I thought that was really interesting
that can it can be it can have a great
potential that can be used to many other
uh display for example like uh you know
you get the photo of Jupiter and then
the the planet is looking like it has a
lamina flow because it has low
resolution uh imaging but actually it's
a lot of combination of small scale
edies in it. So you know probably this
kind of technology can be applied to uh
astronomy like that and then you can
help uh the uh planet atmospheric
science uh to uh rebuild the small scale
edies in their atmosphere. So yeah I was
thinking this is really interesting uh
technology you you got uh thank you.
Thank you. Yeah. Uh another question is
uh that uh I was wondering you know how
your tool could be
uh how do I say that like responsive for
the base flow change. I think you have
uh briefly uh touched that uh in your
slide 38.
So I was just imagining a like
application case uh which could be a
long shot but let's say that the the
plane is equipped with some kind of
lighter uh that can detect the upcoming
uh turbulence in front of the flight
test and then you you know it it
captures that what kind of vortex is uh
existing in in front and and uh it has
the the sensor for the like what is the
speed of the base flow. So it can by
combining this combination and with this
tool maybe it can help uh adjusting the
the angle of clip so they can like
assist the plane to be stabil
stabilized. Uh so I think my question
here is that like for your tool how how
it how it is uh responsive to the base
flows sudden change of base flow which
also uh can be interpreted as like how
this two can be responsive for the
sudden change of lenos number
right so um J thanks for the great
questions um first of all the super
resolution
idea is really pretty awesome. It worked
a lot better than we initially
envisioned. I I think we started on this
endeavor maybe six, seven years ago and
it it turns out to be pretty robust and
the latest things that we've considered
were how do we combine experimental data
maybe low resolution experimental data
and um similar high resolution
computational data. It turns out you can
merge it pretty nicely too to do
reconstruction. So I I I think I think I
well I agree with you that this seems
like a pretty powerful tool and people
are using it various ways. So it's kind
of taking off on its own. Now as far as
this particular thing about um detecting
disturbances, acting on it this is a
really an open problem in my opinion. So
you know a lot about planes. um if you
try to fly there's a question of well
how do we detect it and then how do we
act against it right I don't even know
if you have the right kind of actuator
or control surfaces to respond in a
quick way that can make a huge
difference yet so this is an open
questions not just by ourselves but as a
community and we might have to think of
novel ways to respond and I'm hoping
that some of these time varying base
flow analysis
What they will do is identify whether we
need to change the attitude of the
aircraft in a certain way so that you
fly over the the perturbations or uh
under the perturbations or you directly
fly into it depending on those scenarios
and the timing. I'm hopeful that it will
tell you well put in this type of
perturbation at this right wave number
and frequency content when the vortex is
going exactly over where the actuator is
or maybe the actuator needs to start
doing its own thing a little earlier,
but that timing information will be
given to us, right? And that will really
relate also on the parameters held by
the disturbance that's upstream, right?
So all those information needs to be
processed pretty quickly too, right? So
you we also show through machine
learning that you can detect
perturbations that are approaching
pretty nicely and accurately and if
that's done pretty quickly then the
chances of processing that information
and coming up with a strategy to react
might be possible. So all this I'm kind
of dreaming that we can do this in the
next few years at least for fundamental
problems but I'll be happy to have more
word chat on this because this is not
something just our group can do. This is
something I I need to work with various
people.
Awesome. Thank you so much. Thank you.
Awesome. Thank you. Um so next question
is by Kevin. Kevin, do you want to
unmute yourself and ask yourself?
Yeah, sure. Um thank you for the very
nice talk. Um hi. Yeah, I was very like
amazed at all this result. Um the I I
was interested about the work with the
limit cycle assumptions with the best
synchronization and um how so one of the
my question was um how well would this
limit cycle assumption hold true in the
extreme cost situation because here the
I guess the simulation has the fixed
meaning but then depending on the
extreme cost if we have like the fluid
solid
interactions then the flight wing may
lose stability and it may never come
back to its original steady condition.
So I was wondering would the best
synchronization still apply well in such
a situation.
Devin
uh that's a good question. The hope is
that this is useful, right? I can't
guarantee it. I'm really hopeful this is
useful. Um the reason why is that all
the analysis that we've shown we were
able to compress it to a limit cycle
like representation. I'm not going to
call it a limit cycle because I I
carefully chose sometimes to use the
word cyclic representation, right? So it
it represents something like a cycle. In
those cases, I think we do fairly well.
And in on that cycle like
representation, if you can act within
one cycle, then I think we're good.
Right now, after that one cycle, if the
plane hits a building and it crashes, we
have no hope, right? or if it starts to
become unstable and you know do other
things where you're really far away from
the limit cycle then we're really in
trouble that scenarios we haven't been
able to explore yet right so that's
still where we have to play around with
now one of the things that you might
have noticed is this theta variable
right this big capital theta this phase
function is actually a phase function
that is defined off the limit cycle
right now. How big of a neighborhood
does that phase function uh is that
phase function valid for? That's a case
by case analysis. But I'm hopeful that
we can extend our analysis so that
representation capture a pretty good
range of in in the radial direction. But
that's something I I actually need to
study a little bit more because I'm not
an expert. Well, we we played with phase
reduction analysis, but I can learn
certainly a lot more here to expand our
understanding and I know there are some
theories looking into nonlinear
extensions of these things, but that's a
good question. I I don't have a straight
answer for you. I'm just saying we're
going to be studying that over the next
few years, right? And we have some
friends I I I think Adenire is here. I
mean, I know he's looked into these for
fluid structure interaction type
problems. I know he's not looking into
the fast response, but he's also looking
into more multifysics type problems as
well. So this is you in terms of um
control as well, right? In his case, but
this is something I I think we can
extend quite a bit more. But you know,
uh stay tuned and you know, come back
and see what we're doing in a few years.
Hopefully we'll make a lot more
progress.
Oh yeah, definitely. I really hope to
hear more from from you. Okay, thank you
so much for your response. Yeah, thanks
Kevin. All right. Well, thank you. Thank
you for the nice active
discussion in 20 sessions. Um, is there
any other questions? I don't see anyone
hands up and no more questions in the
chat
room. And now the 10 minutes passed
um uh from our designated time. So I
guess it's a good time to
uh wrap up and thanking our speaker for
the wonderful talk and the discussions
in the Q&A session. Sam, it was a very
nice uh presentations and thank you so
much. I had a lot of fun and thanks a
lot. Thanks a lot for the feedback. I
appreciate it. I look forward to
following up. Yeah. Yeah. I'm sure there
are many people who wants to follow up
with you. Okay. Thank you again. Uh with
that it's conclude the today's DDPS
seminar talk and so let me stop the
recording.